This lecture is about using a time
series as context to potentially
discover causal topics in text.
In this lecture we're going to continue
discussing contextual text mining.
In particular, we're going to look at
the time series as a context for
analyzing text to potentially discover
causal topics.
As usual, let's start with motivation.
In this case, we hope to use text
mining,
to understand the time series. Here
what you're seeing
is Dow Jones industrial average and
stock price curves and you see a sudden
drop here. Right, so one would be interested
in knowing what might have caused the
stock market crash.
Well, if you know the background and you
might be able to figure out if you look
at the time stamp or there are other
data that can help us figure it out.
But the question here is can we get
some clues about this from the
companion news stream and we have a lot
of news data that are generated during
that period.
So if you do that, we might actually
discover the crash actually happened at
the time of September 11 attack.
And that's the time when there is a
sudden rise of the topic,
about the September 11 attack in news
articles.
Here's another scenario where we want
to analyze the presidential
election. This is the time series
data from a presidential prediction
market.
For example, the Iowa electronic market would
have stocks for each candidate, and if
we believe one candidate will win, then
you tend to buy the stock for that candi
date causing the price of that
candidate to increase.
So that's a nice way to actually do
survey of people's opinions about these
candidates.
Suppose you see a sudden drop of price
for one candidate.
You might also want to know what might
have caused the sudden drop.
Or in social science study, you might
be interested in knowing what mattered
in this election, what issues really
mattered to people.
Now, again in this case, we can look at
the companion news stream and ask the
question.
Are there any clues in the news stream
that might provide insight about this.
So, for example, we might discover the
mention of tax cut has
been increasing since that point.
So maybe that's related to the drop of
the price.
So all these cases are special cases of
a general problem of joint analysis
of text and the time series data to
discover causal topics.
The input in this case is a time series
plus text data that are produced in the
same time period-
the companion text stream.
And this is to see this was different
from the standard talking models where
we have just the text collection.
That's why we set time series here to
serve as context.
Now the output that we want to
generate is the topics whose coverage
in the text stream has strong
correlations with the time series.
For example, whenever the topic is
mentioned, the price tends to go down,
etc.
Now we call these topics "causal
topics".
Of course, they're not, strictly
speaking, causal topics or we are never
going to be able to verify whether they
are causal or there's a true causal
relationship here.
That's why we put causal in quotation
marks.
But at least they are correlated topics
that might potentially explain the
cause, and humans can certainly
analyze such topics to understand the
issue better.
And the output so would contain topics
just like in topic modeling.
But we hope these topics are not just
regular topics.  With these topics, we
certainly don't have to explain the
data the best in text, but rather they
have to explain the data in the text,
meaning that they have to represent a
meaningful topics in texts semantically
coherent topics, but also more
important they should be correlated
with the external time series that is
given as a context.
So to understand how we solve this
problem, let's first just to solve the
problem with the regular topic
model.
For example, PLSA and we can apply this
to text streams.
And, with some extension like a CPLSA
or contextual PLSA,
then we can discover these topics in
the collection and also discover their
coverage overtime.
So one simple solution is to choose the
topics from this set that have the
strongest correlation with the external
time series.
But this approach is not going to be
very good.
Why, because we are restricted to the
topics that were discovered by PSA or
LDA?
And that means the choice of topics
will be very limited and we know these
models try to maximize light role of
the text data, so those topics tend to
be the major topics that explain the
text data well, and they're not
necessarily correlated with time
series.
Even if we get the best one, the most
correlated and the topics might still
not be so interesting from causal
perspective.
So here in this work site here,
a better approach, it was proposed, and
this approach is called Iterative
causal topic model.
The idea is to do a iterative
adjustment of topics discovered
by topic models using time series to
induce a prior.
So here's an illustration of how this
works.
How this works.
Take the text stream as input and apply
regular topic modeling to generate a
number of topics.
That said, four topics shown here.
And then we're going to use the
external time series
to assess which topic is more causally
related or correlated with the external
time series, so we can certainly rank
them.
And we might figure out that topic one
and topic four are more correlated and
topic two and topic three are not.
Now we could have stopped here and that
would be just like the simple
approaches that I talked about earlier,
right, then we can get these topics and
call them causal topics.
But as I also explained that these
topics are likely very good because
they are general topics that explained
the whole text collection, they're not
necessarily the best topics that are
correlated with our time
series.
So what we can do in this approach is
to further zoom in the word level.
And we're going to look into each word
in the top ranked word list for each
topic.
Let's say we take topic one as the
target to examine.
We know topic one is correlated with
the time series.
Or this is the best that we could get
from this set of topics so far.
And we're going to look at the words in
this topic -
the Top words.
And if the topic is correlated with the
time series, there must be some words
that are highly correlated with the
time series.
So here, for example, we might discover
W1 and W3 are positively
correlated with time series.
But W2 and W4 are negatively
correlated.
So as a topic and it's not good to mix
these words with different
correlations, so we can then further
separate these words, we're going to
get all the red words that indicate
positive correlation W1and W3,
and we're going to also get another
subtopic, if you  want,
that represents a
negatively correlated words W2 and W4.
Now these subtopics, all these
variations of topics based on the
correlation analysis,
are topics that are still quite related
to the original topic topic one, but
they already deviating because of the
use of time series information,
to bias selection of words.
So they in some sense, well, we should
expect so,
they are in some sense more correlated
with time series than the original
topic one because the original topic one has
mixed words here, we separate them.
So each of these two subtopics can be
expected to be better correlated with
time series.
However, they may not be so coherent
semantically.
So the idea here is to go back to topic
model by using these, each as a prior,
to further guide the topic modeling,
and that's to say we ask our topic
models to now discover topics that are
very similar to
each of these two subtopics, and this
will cause a bias toward more
correlated topics
with the time series.
Of course, then we can apply topic
models to get
another generation of topics, and that
can be further ranked based on the time
series to select the highly correlated
topics.
Then we can further analyze the
component words in the topic and then
try to analyze word level correlation.
And then get the even more correlated
subtopics
that can be further fed into the
process as prior to drive the topic
model discovery.
So this whole process is just heuristic
way of optimizing causality and
coherence.
That's our ultimate goal, right?
So here you see the pure topic models will
be very good at maximizing topical
coherence.
The topicals will be all meaningful.
If we only use causality test or
correlation measure then we might get a
set of words that are strongly
correlated with time series, but they
may not necessarily mean anything.
They might not be semantically
connected, so that will be at the
other extreme on the top.
Now the ideal is to get the causal
topic that's scored high both in
topical coherence, and also causal
relation. And this approach
can be regarded as an alternate way
to maximize both dimensions.
So when we apply the topic models we are
maximizing the coherence.
But when we decompose the topic model
words into sets of words that are
strongly very strongly correlated with
time series, we select the most
strongly correlated words with the time
series we are pushing the model back to
the causal dimension to make it better
in causal scoring.
And then when we apply the
selected words, as a prior to guide
the topic modeling, we again go back to
optimize the coherence because topic
models will ensure the next generation
of topics to be coherent and we can
iterate, iterate, and optimize in this
way as shown on this picture.
So the only component that you
haven't seen in such a framework is how to
measure the causality because the rest
is just topic model.
So let's have a little bit discussion of that.
So here we show that.
Let's say we have a topic about
government response here and then with
topic model,
we can get the coverage of the topic
overtime.
So we have a time series Xt.
Now we also have our given a time
series that represents external
information.
It's a non text time series,
Yt, is the stock prices.
Now the question here is, does Xt cause
Yt?
Or in other words, we want to match the
causality relation between the two.
Or maybe just measure the correlation
of the two?
There are many measures that we can use
in this framework.
For example, Pearson correlation is a
commonly used measure and we can
consider time lag here so that we can
try to capture causal relation using
somewhat past data, using the data
in the past, to try to correlate that
with the data on points on why that
represents the future, for example, and
by introducing such lag we can
hopefully it captures on causal
relation by even using correlation
measures like Pearson correlation.
But a commonly used measure for
causality here is Granger causality
test.
And the idea of this test is actually
quite simple.
Basically you're going to have auto
regressive model to use the history
information of Y to predict itself.
And this is the best we could do
without any other information.
So we're going to be able to use such a
model.
And then we're going to add some
history information of X into such a
model to see if we can improve the
prediction of Y.
If we can.
If we can do that with a statistically
significant difference, then we just
say X has some causal influence on Y
or otherwise we wouldn't have caused
the improvement of prediction of Y.
If, on the other hand, the difference
is insignificant, and that would mean X
does not really have a causal relation
with Y, and so that's the basic idea.
Now we don't have time to explain this
in detail, so you could read, but you
would read this cited reference here to
know more about this measure.
It's very frequently used measure, it has
many applications.
So next, let's look at some sample
results generated by this approach.
Here the data is New York Times and in
the time period of June 2000 through
December of 2011.
And here the time series we used is
stock prices of two companies, American
Airlines and Apple, and the goal here is
to see if we inject some time series
bias or time series
context whether we can
actually get topics that are biased
towards these time series.
Imagine if we don't use any input,
we don't use any context,
then the topics from New York Times
discovered by PLSA would be just general
topics that people talk about in news.
Those major topics in the news event.
But here you see, these topics are
indeed
biased toward each time series.
In particular, if you look at the
underlined words here in the
American Airlines result and you see
airlines, Airport, Air, United, trade,
terrorism, etc.
So it clearly has topics that are
more correlated with the external time
series.
On the right side you see some of the
topics are clearly related to Apple. Right.
So you can see computer technology,
software, Internet, com, web etc.
So that just means the time series has
effectively served as a context to bias
the discovery of topics. From another
perspective
these result help us what people have
talked about in each case, so in the
not just the people what people have
talked about,
but what are some topics that might be
correlated with their stock prices?
And so these topics can serve as a
starting point for people to further
look into
the issues and to find the true causal
relations.
Here are some other results from
analyzing presidential election
Time series.
And the time series data here is from
Iowa electronic market.
And that's a prediction market and the
data is the same.
New York Times from May 2000 to October
2000,
for 2000 presidential campaign
election.
Now what you here are the top 3 words
insignificant topics from New York
Times.
And if you look at these topics and
they are indeed quite related to the
campaign.
Actually, here the issues are very much related
to the important issues of this
presidential election.
Now here I should mention that the text
data has been filtered by using only
the articles that mention these
candidate names.
At.
So it's a subset of these news
articles, very different from the
previous experiment.
But the results here clearly show that
the approach we can uncover some
important issues in that presidential
election.
So tax cut, oil, energy, abortion and
gun control are all known to be
important issues in that presidential
election, and that was supported by
some literature in political science.
And also it was discussed in Wikipedia.
So basically the results show that the
approach can effectively discover
possibly causal topics based on the
time series data.
So there are two suggested readings
here.
One is the paper about this iterative
topic modeling with time series
feedback, where you can find more
details about how this approach works.
And the second one is reading about
Granger causality test.
So in the end, let's summarize the
discussion of text based prediction.
Now,
Text based prediction is generally very
useful for big data applications that
involve text, because,
you can help us infer new knowledge
about the word and the knowledge can
go beyond what's discussed in the text.
As a result, they can also support
optimizig of our decision making, and
this has widespread applications.
Text data is often combined with non
text data for prediction, because for
this purpose, for the prediction purpose, we
generally would like to combine non
text data and text data together as
much clues as possible for prediction.
And so as a result, joined analysis of
text and non text is very necessary.
And it's also very useful now when we
analyze text data together with non
text data we can see they can help each
other.
So non text data provide context for
mining text data and we discussed a
number of techniques for contextual
text mining.
And on the other hand, text data can also help
interpret the patterns
discovered from non text data and this
is called a pattern annotation.
And in general this is a very active
research topic and there was there new
papers being published and there are
also many open challenges that have to
be solved.